a year listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network let's start
with a prayer no it's that coat touch
Manson hands and start with the prayers
off that's good a little thanks did you
put your hands over the goddamn ants
finish the intro
first of all finish the intro finish the
intro to the podcast this is a bilingual
American history podcast each week I
read a story in traditional Hebrew and
English from America from American
history what a train wreck every week
just that my name is Dave Anthony relate
to my friend here Reynolds who has no
idea what the topic is going to be about
it's not true yeah most / the prayer no
and called it quote is jam-packed jammed
I'm the [ __ ] guy Dave okay and this
is not gonna tickle you sick arguments
all right that's like a real show do you
got any dates coming up yeah I'm dating
your mom this Friday sort of the music
again no is that what happens is that a
penance are we off the music we're off
the music okay February 20th and 21st
this is a little confusing but this is
for Illinois
I'll be at Rosemont Zanies in Illinois
and then the 22nd and the 23rd I'll be
in the Chicago zannies and then March
1st and March 2nd which is a Friday and
Saturday I'll be at Zanies
Nashville so that's as a nice traffic
gans that we're calling it's the same
Stravaganza pnes and i'll be doing that
don't February 8th we will be in
Philadelphia
February 9th we'll be in Atlanta the
16th of March will be in Durham North
Carolina people are saying they don't
want two tickets master for that one you
can call the theater directly and avoid
Ticketmaster gouging hey you know who's
coming to the derm show ooh
Chad the dude who oh [ __ ] yeah the UPS
guy yeah great
love it Brooklyn on the 18th of May
Columbus that dates got to be wrong this
is how there's March 30th March 30th
we'll be right back wait where yeah
dollop Columbus yeah March 30th that's
what I have let's see is that in your
email or is that all no it's in your
calendar okay so it's probably right so
March 30 most like so we'll be in
Columbus on March 30th that you know so
basically we there are some of these are
Ticketmaster we're gonna we're gonna try
and do less of that some of these were
kind of shotgunned out fast and yeah
we're gonna put more thought into so we
apologize for the Ticketmaster [ __ ]
the new year means new resolutions
Gareth seamless and we've got one you're
working on twice every day it's your
mouth it's your mouth hole maybe three
times a day there is no way that they
have asked for you - they said term
mouth they did they said mouth oh I'm
talking about quip the electric
toothbrush the thing you put in your
mouth hole to scrub your hard won
certain reading off of the iPad so I use
equip use equip we both enjoy your clips
and whole families is equipped now yeah
we're equip family yeah it's great
it's got sensitive sonic vibration for
an effective clean that's gentle on your
sensitive gums because some people brush
too hard yeah I did you did yes and some
electric toothbrushes are too abrasive
but not the quip yes
that's right built in two minutes you
use it right you are very good with
off-the-cuff one-liners at a party hey
guys it has a built-in two-minute timer
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you
when to switch sides that's great
multi-use cover works as a stand mount
two mirrors slide over your bristles to
pack and protect your quip on the go yep
I bring on a trips now I slap it to the
mirror on the hotel's booked trips trip
slap it to the mirror in the hotel it's
pretty great that's my favorite thing
brush heads are automatically diluting
it again an automatic brush setup so
every three months a new brush comes you
pop it on boom yep you're good to go yep
it's delightful
Equipe is one of the first electric
toothbrushes accepted by the American
Dental Association
you know actually quip was a lot like
Dylan because they used to just make
regular toothbrushes and then they went
electric I'm gonna stop talking during
the commercials you're great so that's a
little clip and why over a million happy
healthy mouths do to equip starts just
$25 and if you go to get equip comm
slash dollop right now you can get your
first refill pack for free that's your
first
refill pack free at GE t qu IP comm
slash dollop we are also brought to you
by zip recruiter
what Garak or Walmart move on care core
only is that's all you need to say Garak
or zip recruiter big buzz names okay
so zip recruiter well you threw me off
it's not you I mean it's how much I
threw you off I almost spit everywhere
so zip recruiter obviously is an online
hiring site job boards you can send your
candidates that what the [ __ ] oh I see
sorry I can't this is a bad copy so the
job boards right you what do you use for
care core what's your what what would
use before a zip recruiter well before
zip recruiter what we would do is we
would set up a box sort of like how a
child would set up a lemonade stand and
we would bark at popular intersection so
how many how many people did you get
coming in on that I hired over five dogs
okay say no I didn't realize you're
hiring dogs I wasn't trying to I was
trying to hire people but they just kind
of collect it around so here's what you
should you should go to zip recruiter
calm okay
slash dollop to hire the right person
unlike other job side zip recruiter
finds qualified candidates for you it's
powerful matching technology skins
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience picking up cats shaving a
heavy cat figuring out what she wants a
cat a seal just the standard stuff at
the job site and actively invites them
you think those are things that are
happening at Kara Courtney's you're out
of your mind I do that's exactly right
keep thinking that having fun with that
and meanwhile we're never my
revolutionary revolutionising the
bottling and the kite business okay and
while that's not a thing there's no kite
business anymore exactly zip recruiters
rated number one by employers in the US
this rating comes from hiring sites on
trust pilot with over a thousand reviews
and right now our listeners can try
zipper here for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter calm a slash
dollop if you love the show your show
yours
to it and the zip recruiter by going to
zip recruiter comm slash deal
Opie that's zip recruiter comm slash dot
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
we should point out that we are doing
this episode in Burpo test you know and
the all things comedy studio so if you
want to watch us do this you can go to
the all things comedy YouTube page and
buy oh if I may it is dynamic to watch I
mean who wouldn't
what about this isn't okay I did my
video face yeah it's terrible it's a
nightmare
16:25 you've our Lord Jesus Christ can
we just start with one prayer now we
just start with one
Nellore a handful of Dutch West India
Company settlers had spent the winner on
Governors Island to set up a fur trading
post okay in the early summer they
started moving to Manhattan along with a
hundred newcomers who had just arrived
from Amsterdam okay by the middle of
September they had moved their cows and
horses on to Manhattan okay sure it's a
different vibe now it's gotta be hard to
get a I mean you're you ever taking a
cow across on a canoe or something like
that yeah no never done that you
surprised with my answer no yeah yeah
actually we're never canoed a cow I've
never counted Oh
come on let's go people start turning
this off oh I was I was doing video
stuff yeah so now they had to build
enough housing to survive the winter
okay
they did in a year later they had around
30 houses okay it's a lot quote made of
the bark of trees sure sure sure sure
weird sure I mean are we just pointing
out how thin the homes are it's not a
great I mean generally I feel like that
would fail like a inspection inspection
yeah so you made this out of bark yeah
but this is load-bearing bark sir so you
need this bark here otherwise the bark
roof will come down and you know we
could all get a sore arm okay so the
thing is there's actually no such thing
as load-bearing bark well let me take
you to the man cave because I think
you'll see there it's all load berry
bark look at that huh you believe that
yeah I believe it it's not this is not
looking here huh
did you think about using wood what no
okay this is all built on the West Side
Manhattan three years later in August
1628 the settlers were quote beginning
to build sturdy new houses to replace
the hovels and huts okay so they've
moved beyond bark yeah so now they're
like let's actually build someplace well
actually have a hot a bark Hut bark huts
that's not great no legend had it that
the Dutch started their move to
Manhattan on the 1st of May and legend
legend I mean even if it's not true I'm
not gonna be that impressed okay and
that on each May Day anniversary after
they would repeat it by leaving their
houses and moving to a new one okay
little musical chairs but for a house on
a certain day yeah what sort of like an
elaborate clock would do every hour
that's right right a Dutch encyclopedia
from 1696 says the first day of May was
called Bruce dog or moving day sure
where you would just literally leave
your house you move on that day so just
every May every first vacate new house
new house got a new house all right
it was standard to have leases whether
commercial or residential expired I'm a
first year I was signing one year jump
to hit okay so that's the day people
moved on May 1st
some locations in England May 1st was
known as pack rag day sure doesn't
surprise me I swear to God if you told
my other pack rag day there I mean she
still has a tremendous amount of rag
yeah time to pack the rags ooh this is a
good rag I don't think my mother's said
who put the rag there oh that's a nice
rag things I've literally heard from so
it was called that because that was the
day when servants would put their
possessions in a bundle and switch
employers at hiring fairs switch okay so
you're so may it's kind of like you
versus me you just change everything
you're starting over
you're just a no new home new new career
yep new spouse sure why not yeah yeah
like moving day in New York went on like
this for over a hundred years so
starting at 1625 it just keeps [ __ ]
on everyone did it on the same day
everybody's moving every May 1st yeah in
1809 Washington Urban Irving wrote quote
the members love doing this to nothing
well I mean just the fact that you're
already like wait a minute what is
happening it's crazy that is crazy
yeah the fact that every main front
you're like man I love this Bob but hey
you know what I mean it's April 30th but
they were like everyone started doing it
60 25 let's just keep it going
ok so Washington Irving wrote quote the
memorable emigration of the great
settlers to New Amsterdam took place on
the 1st of May and was long cited in
tradition as the grand moving the
anniversary the anniversary of it was
piously observed among their sons by
turning their houses topsy-turvy and
carrying all their furniture into the
streets this what I mean you when it may
2nd must have been a great day when your
god it's nice furniture Street day every
single person let's
oh so that's 1809 so we're almost 200
years in and there's still may moving
there still may moving on my first okay
and it was further solidified when in
1820 of the New York State Legislature
passed a law that made all leases end on
the 1st of May I'm not I'm not gonna
pull over my amazement at this but every
you must just be I mean it's like the
purge of apartments it's mayhem okay
yeah it is a little it is a little
purging
yeah I just might ringers on because I
had that's how I still care about you
it's not it's got nothing to do with
that what's happening well what's
happening what's happening is is that
you wouldn't pray with me and now I
think my prayers so so so they passed
this law lease is not on the may effort
or May first though the number of people
within who Worth and leases at that time
was small minority so you don't have the
Manhattan we see today of tons of
buildings and apartments it's a lot of
just houses and then there's some leases
you know but it's not a huge deal right
tenants would find out if their rent was
going to increase on February 1st and
then that gave them three months to find
a new place or to decide to stay with
the new rent increase okay so most
people decide to stay in their old place
until the very last minute for whatever
reason okay a city ordinance
so it basically are like climate change
policy yep it's the same thing a city
ordinance stated tenants not renewing
their lease had to leave their building
by 9:00 o'clock a.m. and be in their new
place by 80 question be in their new
place by 3:00 p.m. okay but a lot of
people had no idea where they work this
is May 1st and people don't know where
they're going well at that point if you
know you're hiding you should have a
place lined up if you can line one I
mean maybe you can't but you have you
have to find a place by 3:00 p.m. you
have six hours to move all your [ __ ]
okay
that's fine that's normal not normal
stressful I'm stressed a writer quote
year after year on the freighter I know
I didn't know who was a writer quote
year after year on the first of May the
universal moving day
homeless people gathered in the park
with their goods and chattels and were
lodged in the jail until the houses they
had rented could be got ready for them
so people who so now these are people
who are breaking lot so these are people
who place is not ready yet
right so so they just go to the jail ok
god damn what so if you didn't have your
crazy made a move lined up you've went
to jail yeah you had to have it ready
yet to be anyplace by 3 p.m. if not you
just go to the park and then you're in
your homeless yeah and you're put in
jail ok so this is when there was enough
like prisons for the homeless I guess so
yeah right there was also a major change
because with empty buildings landlords
could get busy the mayor wrote about it
on the moving day 18:26 quote the
pulling down of houses and stores in the
lower parts is awful
bricks rafters and slates are showered
down in every direction it looks like
the ruin from an earthquake further up
at the corner of Chambers Street a row
of low buildings has been removed to
make way for one of those mighty
structures called a hotel eating
drinking and lodging above with merry
shops below so these these these guys
are not the you own a building you're
taking advantage of it you want to build
a bigger building so you take advantage
of May 1st and when everyone vacates you
just [ __ ] tear that [ __ ] down and
start so on May 1st is also adverse this
is the day when you can decide to
rebuild page one rewrite your place and
so you imploded so on May 1st yeah
everybody's moving furniture some people
who don't have homes are being jailed
because they're now technically how they
should be they're illegal and building
owners are just deciding now that they
could just explode they're dumb start a
new one build the hotel now now you can
build the hotel but the [ __ ]
Ferguson's are gone this is normal so
buildings start getting bigger more
people moving into those buildings the
next year there was a yellow
fever epidemic okay and this would have
been a great time for us to pray banks
and stores were forced to move to
makeshift structures on Bank Street a
paper wrote quote Greenwich is no longer
a country village such has been the
growth of our city that the building of
one block will sorry of the building of
one block more will connect the two
places and in three years time
Greenwich will be known only as a part
of the city and the suburbs will be
beyond them
so basically Greenwich is blowing up
okay become a big place now on Lots that
just had a house there were tenements so
right there'd been a house before now
there's very quickly as it's happening
city's exploding now there's ten minutes
with 80 to 150 people living and okay
most were built quickly to house
immigrants who were arriving from Europe
with not a lot of money and no job they
had three rooms a front room two
bedrooms plumbing was almost
non-existent except each time would have
a backyard outhouse or a pump I think
it's safe to say your initial statements
still true
I just just just so we know where how
I'm a just so we know where I'm at yeah
let's try it with you taking with me I
would rather die than share a bathroom
with 80 people but not a bathroom day
not a bath you it's a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
it's not a bath sir it's an outhouse
yeah I mean really the only thing that
separating it from just regular land is
four walls and a hole yeah yeah no so so
I'd rather be dead right okay like right
there I'm not going back in time just
kill me I don't want that I don't want
any part of what's happening don't you
the line so what you can't go to a
concert for a weekend I'm not gonna [ __ ]
in a concert what are you gonna do I'm
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] before I go or hold
that in I'm not gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] sea but you'd never go to like
Coachella and like just being the
elements for like yeah I'm not gonna do
that anymore
there were times when I did but I'm not
gonna I wouldn't either but I just love
to picture you there just you know with
your legs crossed like legs I mean I
like the Foo Fighters but so
right we'll get back to those we'll get
back to those times yeah the
neighborhood's reached densities of half
a million people per square mile
a resident quote to live a family of
eight in three rooms seemed quite normal
as was being without a bathroom and
sharing the toilet with three neighbors
oh so that's right there it's 24 people
- uh - it oh no that's more that's right
eight times yeah that it's 32 this is
the 30 says he's talking about 404 okay
neighbors for me I'm sure 34 humans to
it 32 he mr. toilet lax number to me
this is the toilet apocalypse like this
is yeah yeah it's the apocalypse they
knew it sucked and that they had it
worse off than others so they knew that
they were living in a shitty situation
because they other houses right they
quote knew that by American standards
they were victims of an outrage an
outhouse rage an outhouse rich but they
also remembered that in the old country
many of them had lived in hovels so they
submitted as best they could to their
daily burdens determined to escape as
quickly as possible
okay working-class people could not
afford to ride in horse carriages or
later the street cars that came so most
New Yorkers tried to live close to where
they worked okay that make sense the
Lower East Side was working-class and
immigrants to the west side it was where
merchants and professionals lived okay
pros right the peeps for the pros
prescription sorry a description if
lower Manhattan Irish neighborhood quote
a dozen gruesome doorways Gabe I'm gonna
say first let me say this person is not
a huge fan of yard well they make your
first half sentence sort of shows that
would you like a doorway gruesome you're
digging a dozen gruesome doorways gave
up loads of babies to the street and the
gutter the doorway is just like baby
[ __ ] to the street babies rolling out
like a wave of just like me
- I'm Toby I'm Tory do you fresh from
the womb garments fluttered from fire
escapes in all unhandy places there were
buckets brooms rags and bottles in this
street I mean those kind of are the
essentials that's the Irish mocha normal
and the street infants played or fought
with other infants that's playing or sat
stupidly in the way of vehicles this
person is just stupid
the babies just dumb look at these
stupid Irish babies and Wall Street you
want to go watch the infants fight
former will women with uncombed hair and
disordered dress gossips while leaning
on railings or screamed and frantic
quarrels wizards awesome yeah
withered persons
withered persons and curious postures of
submission sat smoking pipes in obscene
corners this is made by the way the
building quivered and creaked from the
weight of humanity stamping about in its
bowels so that person doesn't is not a
huge fan of the tenement a set dresser
for a musical it's really not great yeah
so it's a packed tenement it's a [ __ ]
full of Irish it's not great no one no
one wants a giant building for Irish
probably not even the Irish that I was
ready to move on obviously the person
who wrote that did not have a big grasp
of poverty no I would imagine now it
wasn't uncommon for people to live in a
dozen dozen houses in a dozen years okay
so you would literally just move every
[ __ ] year Lord and those same people
would talk about wanting to move again
to try another neighborhood out it's
it's like though it's really [ __ ]
weird yeah I think it just became the
norm right so it's going on for a couple
hundred years now so I mean when I get
it in a way like the idea of going to
checking out a different neighborhood
but it's also like having that I mean I
guess we just have so much stuff now
moving is such a nightmare I would
imagine that Elijah I just think that
they it's just what you did
yeah well and by the way I mean this is
this sort of [ __ ] still happens you know
it's like if you're in some like drug
torn country they will like you know
drug torn drug infested I there's
warlord yeah I came from a country torn
apart by magic mushrooms you wish but
they will like they'll like bust up you
know they bust up a building at like 3
p.m. and it's like you gotta go yeah
that's it buddy moving on yep so so
though at this point it was actually
very hard to rent for longer than a year
ok so it's both sides like the people
want to move but also the landlords make
it hard for you to stay right because if
the land let's get you out they can
raise the rent right either way they can
raise the rent really 85 % of New
Yorkers live within two miles of Union
Square Davy Crockett visited and wrote
quote we drove up to the city and took a
view of the improvements and beautiful
houses in the new part by the time he
returned down Broadway it seemed to me
that the city was flying before some
awful calamity I was told it was moving
day every Street playground Davy
Crockett to New York on moving day it's
like what the [ __ ] oh boy every street
was crowded with carts wagging them
people so yeah he just saw it he was
like oh Crockett he was like what the
[ __ ] is going on hey come on it's me
a resident quote in every direction
there were carts and wagons laden with
furniture
the streets were literally filled with
chairs tables drawers desk carpets etc
passing from one house to another is so
weird the movers loved it yeah the
movers loved it
inside the busy day you know it's the
day we work I mean people like give a
Halloween store [ __ ] magic being a mover
you get one day one day I take 364 off
one day a year it's a crazy day though
oh my god holy [ __ ] might my dogs are
barking yeah any day it's a busy the
busy time of the day we call it we're
good day yeah it's working day on moving
day Cartman they're called Cartman
because they had carts sure I made
double wages so did the quote New York
gossips
they would use moving day they didn't
make double they didn't make double
wages they loved it also gossips sorry
Oh gossips okay right I was like they're
paying god I was like did you hear they
would use moving day to peep into the
lodgings of strangers because as Mayday
got closer landlords would post a rent
notice and then people would come and
just go look at apartments
so not only are people coming through
who actually want to live there yeah
it's just like you're coming through to
just look you see how your professional
gossipers we've always been the same we
just haven't had a phone forever some
are actually looking at the space others
came to look at your [ __ ] and see how
you lived quote it is almost impossible
for a stranger who has occupied lodgings
and wishes to escape in position to
avoid such intrusion into his private
rooms we had we have suffered this
ourselves and therefore speak from
experience
okay so there's no law like now your
landlord has to give you 24 hours right
if he comes over right so show the place
but then they can just [ __ ] show up
and again he's smoking weed needing
cereal hey yeah don't say yeah when I'm
talking to her place or no pants that
really opens up so you get two of these
closet [ __ ] in one the 40 people and the
one over there I like cuz it really
opens up but the other one that seems to
be that's my area for refuse I suppose
[ __ ] but I like everything I hear and I
got to find a place because it's my
first time so you only can look at
really one place all right well I think
once you get the hose on this guy and I
get all his stuff out and uh yeah I'll
definitely add I'm interested I'm
interested all right well get that
closet cleaned guys a nightmare
american-born women spent a lot of their
free time going into the apartments of
foreigners to see if they were
respectable and had their rooms well
furnished so I mean white women let's
let's throw in some racism why
yeah so native-born American white women
are just cruising around looking at the
filthy Irish and the filthy Germans in
the filthy English and Italians and
judging and being [ __ ] quote
Americans could not have invented any
domestic custom more prying or which
gives a greater access to the privacy of
strangers right this is cool yeah
totally cool yeah immigrants were
shocked by moving day and thought it was
stupid hmm interesting
I'm sorry we do what here oh you guys
probably do something foolish where
you're from see every May first we all
just leave and find a new place with all
of our stuff and if you don't you go to
jail welcome to the USA are you [ __ ]
idiot I'm walking away one English woman
said it looked like the population was
abandoning abandoning the city due to a
plague
everyone's just [ __ ] streaming out of
the house of others [ __ ] yeah although I
don't know how much moving you do when
you have the plague or when someone has
the plague well I think she's saying
that that not that people they're scared
of getting the plague so yeah but either
but even if you're scared of getting the
plague you're like we'll find a new bed
we get there we'll do it we'll do a shop
yeah we'll hit Pier one Imports we'll
buy some is everything again it's
airborne
okay everyone should we bring the rat
absolutely bring the rat okay you mean
my tea yeah yeah everyone seemed to be
annoyed by it but was unavoidable if you
rented it was the way it was people
actually started building houses just to
avoid moving day yeah that makes total
yes right under people price that we're
coming in your place like what's the
deal here I own this well commodified
rummage through your stuff yeah yes yes
this is my house you actually can't come
into it guy use your toilet no nope how
did you toilet don't have a toilet
closet can I go on your lap nope
can I go on my lap no not here
alright having a know hey it's gonna be
my don't do it dance thank you
writer lydia maria child called moving
day the saddest thing she had ever seen
children were on the street caring what
they could for their parents
the dogs looked bewildered and the cat
sat on doorsteps meowing quote so they
were the animals were the exact same the
animals were also like what the [ __ ]
must have just I mean they must go crazy
oh my god imagine cats on movie I cannot
it's like a cat apocalypse at that point
quote human being collapse I had to
because you did one and I didn't you
didn't have to do that that's the thing
I wait for my quote human beings are
such creatures of habit and imitation
that what is necessity soon becomes
fashion and each one wishes to do what
everyone else is doing a lady in the
neighborhood closed all her blinds and
shutters on May Day when asked by her
friend whether she had been in the
country she answered I was ashamed to
not be moving on the 1st of May so I
shut up the house that the neighbors
might not know it she felt like a pariah
for not moving that's right so it's so
everyone is so into moving now on the
first to depressed because she did she
wasn't depressed she was shamefully
hiding because she didn't want people to
see her not moving like some kind of
[ __ ] animal what is your plan may 2nd
for everyone that's been to your place
over the last year mm-hmm well ok so
what you just shut your blinds for one
day and then you're like I guess it's
just on that day she cuz it's like when
you're when you when you're at a party
it'd be inferred from the fact that you
are staying in the same place that you
didn't move May first so the shame that
you're hiding from May first you're
gonna feel for the month of May on the
day of the event it's like if you go to
a toga party and you're wearing jeans
and a shirt on that day you feel like an
[ __ ] so it's just that day no it's
not it is no it isn't you're and you
know Jo what it's not moving game boom
you don't know what moving day is like
for us what are you talking about
entire neighborhoods would be broken up
so everyone in the neighborhood is gone
and when it was over people would not
know where to look for their friends
because everyone had frankly critically
taken off to their new place
make new friends you know what I mean
we'll just find new everything will just
find new friends every may I mean we
make new friends like I assume you tell
like your close friends you like hey
Larry bill I'm moving but then you
forgot to tell Jeff and Garry and then
everyone everyone is moving it's not one
person everyone's moving and there's no
phone oh hey Ted I thought you were bill
where's bill
[ __ ] maybe we'll see him again maybe not
yeah that's what that's one of the
perils of moving day well it's it's hard
to live but it's but no it's what we do
the Brooklyn daily eagle in a trade
publication the best it's an eagle the
Brooklyn daily eagle in 1847 said a
large part of the year was spent
restoring the order that had been
disturbed by moving day sure I really
think what this era needs is somebody to
say hey everybody let's just take a
timeout yeah now every single May we
lose our [ __ ] as a town yeah let's stop
doing that you can stay in a place no
for a while okay so counter argument
yeah it's what we do the landlords were
very much down with moving day and let
them easily raise rents so it's easier
to raise rent on a new person than it is
a person that stays there right and the
daily Eagle said they would resist
getting rid of it so landlords want it
people think it's fashionable huh
the paper called for the laws that led
to moving day to be changed for the
public good and convenience but the law
was contrary to
so that's eight 1847 so we're now 125
years into moving day people who owned
real estate used moving day to gauge the
state of the market if it was a day of
total chaos that meant the market was
good it was a calm day them at the
market was bad it's if the market is
good every year the markets gets chaos
and now you have surveyors out there to
mow mean they're pissed but they're not
livid pissed I didn't see them any angry
dogs this year running around not
knowing where they were yeah I mean like
predicting Groundhog Day seems as good
in 1854 the New York Times wrote about
how great the market was for landlords
quote we chanced to be in downtown
office the other day when the house
agent guy for the landlord made his call
the rooms were rented at 1200 last year
that's a lot of [ __ ] money
yeah 1200 that's a lot of [ __ ] money
New York 1850 for you has always been at
rush 1200 1200 the rooms were rented at
1200 last year this he said was very low
oh yeah this is New York quote too low
to secure a good tenant like yourself
now we must have 1600 of from the first
of may such rewards for good tenants we
here are common this season the rise in
rent is from twenty to thirty three
percent Wow so they're jacking up but
it's not rent control there's no no
there's no this is this is the free
market baby the libertarian dream right
yeah some people enjoyed the hell out of
it for them moving day became a day of
ritual celebration they danced in the
streets and lit bonfires particularly in
the poorer neighborhoods alright good so
just to add a little missus - to the
party there's fires yes great
when writer Seba smith saw the bonfires
he thought the tenants were angry and
rioting and going to burn the city down
no no no they celebrated
why wouldn't they be it's a day of
moving Center moving but it turned out
they were just burning their old straw
beds which have become a tradition
they've keep going but on moving day
everyone now burned their straw bedding
hey I'll let you know when I see
something crazy I'll stop you just a
bunch of straw beds burning in the
streets while everyone's moving boys
would dance around the fire and poke it
with sticks while chanting hoorah hoorah
for we roast bed bugs and fleas hark
hear the fleas roar and the bud bucks
crack and snapped like burning sticks
you need to go it's just a normally
would leave I need you to leave
have you ever now say you're having a
romantic night with a lady have you ever
just thrown some bedbugs on the fire or
fleas and just heard them scream or pop
it's pretty pretty great slip into
something a little more comfortable yeah
and then come back in a velvet suit as
they did this so as the fires are
burning the cartman had to steer around
the mess and fires as they move people's
belongings to their new houses of course
that's right this is just a new and a
new thing to do and the fires made a
moving that's right
at first the movers were farmers from
Long Island who had wagons to ran so
back in the day farmers would come in
but now it's all Cartman and it's a
business sure in the beginning so the
cart sorry the Cartman were licensed now
well ok people do not think much of the
Cartman ok their lack of concern for
clients was legendary ok so that hasn't
changed much movers are still movers
yeah I feel like there's some good ones
for sure yeah there's good movers you
know what you do work with the movers Oh
move with the movers become one with the
movers you know then you're on the team
and then you can watch what's going not
funny or interesting no it said I'm
Serge you'd leave chair yeah
no you do not take chair you know I take
chair no sure heavy you leave chair no
I'm taking the chair cheers not head
okay boys just eight people uh sorry
something would always end up broken or
lost her in the move and Cartman were
known to get into fistfights with each
other and get arrested on moving day
great that's great when you move to when
you're moving all of your things on a
whim to go find a new some other guy
pulls over the cart and then your cart
men get into a fight yeah you got two
carts head-to-head you [ __ ] get
ice-cream each other next thing your
punch I'm not worse that could happen
one of the bedbug straw fires hits your
cart and all your things burn yeah from
Isaac Lyons recollections of an old
Cartman quote during the last two weeks
of April of each year the Cartman begin
to put on an attitude and look and act
with more importance than any other time
yeah their value yeah I guess so bro hey
I don't want any BS media you need a
mover I need a Cartman to help me move
that's right for me first
yeah that's cool I could probably do
that okay so a couple things I'm gonna
need from you I'm not gonna lie
go ahead off to a rocky start go ahead
and call me Lord okay that is not so
you're making a mistake right now don't
look me in the eyes I am gonna
absolutely look you in the eyes and I'm
going to look you in the eyes to tell
you I have a problem your first rule
okay how you gonna move your [ __ ] I'm
gonna go talk to another Cartman Lord
Johnson cuz he's over there you can talk
to Lord Johnson who you want don't look
him in the eyes you don't like it I'll
go talk to nobody likes it I we're all
Lords now we go talk to Lloyd Johnson
and I guess okay
piece of [ __ ] what's your problem I'm a
mover who keeps a [ __ ]
everybody then started calling the
Cartman mr. Cartman he becomes very
domineering and everybody feels that
isn't their interest if not their duty
to bow and cringe to him oh we're on
that day of all the year it is generally
admitted that a Cartman may charge any
price that he pleases this is the perch
soapy there's not a rule there's not a
rule to be found so people start being
super nice to the Cartman because they
don't want him to suck your dick let's
charge so much money yeah yeah yeah it
makes sense
I mean it's how our government functions
now the times started calling moving day
the Cartman's harvest that's a great
band that is the Brooklyn daily eagle
said Cartman were one of the most
necessary evils of moving day oh it's
not true what would you do otherwise
stay I don't understand they could
charge what they wanted be as rude as
they want it and smash smash furniture
without consequences not okay people on
moving day were at the Cartman's mercy
everyone just knew price gouging was
part of the deal on moving day many New
Yorkers had to pay an entire week's wage
to move it's basically income tax yeah
it's at I mean because every day every
you know like I mean basically at one
one day ish every year or around one
time we all are losing our minds trying
to get it all together and then we do it
and we recognize that we're getting
[ __ ] but we just want to be over it
and start the next job so this is a this
is a version of a private industry tax
so a useless industry so the city maze
law made laws regulating what the
Cartman could legally charge articles
would then be published the night before
in the papers the night before moving
day so the public knew how much the
Cartman could legally charge Dave I'm
I'm not trying to poke holes go ahead
why is it the night before why why could
this not have happened a week before so
that you can have a little bit of a
chance to get your head straight before
you go into I think nightmare day I
think because maybe you know it's it's a
big week that's a big week leading
everybody's literally nothing that day
if you publish it the day before
then when the Cartman comes that day you
can go no this is how much it's supposed
to cost is that not possible a week
prior yeah but yeah I don't know it's
very hard moving moving weeks hard yeah
it sounds like you made your argument at
a bar but the problem with this is is
that the number of movers is limited
there's not that many Cartman which
allowed them to keep charging crazy high
amounts and people would just pay it the
city ordinances for Cartman in 1869
stated they could only charge 60 cents
per load for half a mile and one-third
for each additional mile they did not
have to take the goods to a particular
part of the house they could just take
it and dump it in the front fine we'll
take it if a mover was taken advantage
of by Cartman they could complain to
officer David beat Jones inspector of
hacks in the comedy world officer Jones
he was working the club inspector of
hacks [ __ ] he's coming down tonight
how is everybody I don't want to take a
two-minute time I heard Carlos Mencia is
performing I just want to take a look
Kyle ceases no longer here right cease
all right well if you see him let me
know I'll leave you my card I'm
inspector of hacks officer Jones said he
would rule in favor of anyone who went
to the trouble to make out a complaint
against a Cartman okay he's just like
he's down to investigate he's like
anybody who can play [ __ ] those guys so
I'm the inspector and my rule is [ __ ]
those guys hey inspector hacks what
happened to you well back in the day you
see one of the Cartman here
I'm sorry I don't talk about it much
because uh not good a process in
emotions that's why I'm on the force
you know the inspector force but uh
that's why those best that's can do know
right in my eyes so if you got a
complaint against one of these Carmen
you let me know I don't they tried to
buff it out but you can still sort of
see it underneath the varnish I gotta be
honest I don't care I think you're
overreacting it's an I'm worried it's
totally functional and we pushed it up
against the wall but for someone to move
it you would see it plain as day I mean
if you studied it it's a squinter you
know what I mean you got to split this
so you have really incredible emotional
issues ha ha nothing to do with the
armoire raffle quote a well-known
hairdresser everyone knows me you'll
never forget a good hairdresser hello
well-known hairdresser at the Astor
House named Signori a Kris the door oh
hello I am Christopher d'Oro you may
call me Senora I'm polish I had been a
tenant for 13 years starting in 1842
at 1300 per year okay in 1850 the rate
the rent
I know thirteen hundred years it's
insane for 1842 are we wrong are you
wrong for a year yeah but but still I
mean it's still a shitload yeah for 1842
and 1847 the lease was renewed for seven
years at 1500 so five years later Joseph
I'd like an NFL contract as far as if we
pick up the option that'll be another
two years dependent but if you get
injured and you don't stay in the place
for the 80% of your contract we have
every right to evict you so five years
agos up $200 okay then in 1854 it was
increased to 3,000
750 it is going to be 1300 a month in no
time he tried to bargain with the
landlord
but the landlord wasn't interested when
this got attention in the media and it
was pointed out that Krista d'Oro had
made improvements and decorations
the landlord agreed to meet with him
again okay let me discuss it why not
offer a haircut sweeten the pot and he
said quote sir you deserve some mark of
my favour I will do for you what I would
do for no new tenant $50 should come up
off the shop is yours three thousand
seven hundred a year don't do anything
for ya put my hand out to be shaken for
sure so I mean it almost tripled in what
12 years yeah
Rhett's katene sheet up as the New York
Times called it up surd businesses were
being destroyed
landlords used any opportunity to raise
rent
I mean landlords are all just the
monopoly guy right yeah yes oh [ __ ] yeah
they still are the ability to raise
rents was not due to vacancy rates but
moving day which created which created
confusion distraction combinations of
property owners and intense speculation
and tenement housing yeah so it just it
just creates chaos and then from that
they get profit like they use it to
their advantage well David's a familiar
ingredients rich guy would buy a
building and then immediately raise
rents and then resell the building for a
profit because he just raised the rent
so a guy would just buy a building say
the rents increased 500 H and then
selling go this is how much more it's
worth that's crazy
thousands of buildings were changing
houses were changing hands like this so
all these houses guys are just buying it
saying the rents now this and then
selling it to someone else some houses
in the Bronx in Brooklyn were being sold
several times in one month huh every guy
that bought it would just raise the rent
mid month Brett raised twice excuse me
no I already came by I know we're doing
it again so it's my Billy's been sold
six times this month I know it's crazy
to markets nuts any
you always you know like 1500 whatever
then there were there was releasing a
buildings and landlord who owned too
many buildings to manage release a whole
building to someone for a fixed annual
amount this is just I mean the layers
it's like yeah yeah then that guy so the
guy is leasing a building and then he's
charging everyone in the building rent
and managing it and then that guy would
turn around and raise the rents and cut
down on services to make a profit so you
a nice a building from the landlord then
you charge your with higher rents and
then you cut down on services this clown
I gotta make a little money out of my
building huh but not my building but you
know what I mean you know in the
building of anyway it is your toilet
bucket hope you'll enjoy it
it's 40 a buck this especially happened
in Jewish communities on the Lower East
Side Williamsburg and Brownsville the
lessee was hated because the
neighborhood thought he was taking
advantage of his fellow countryman it
was chaos
many a slab in the mid-1800s wrote about
what they saw on moving day New Yorker
lawyer George Templeton strong quote
every house seems to be discouraging
itself into the streets all the
scourging all the sidewalks are lumbered
with bureaus and bedsteads to the utter
destruction of their character as
thoroughfares Anthony Trollope quote a
furniture rich furniture and a ragged
furniture carts wagons and raised ropes
and canvas and straw
Pacers porters a drayman yellow white a
black occupy the street front east to
west north to south Dave let me maybe
present it to our listeners in a way
that kind of makes you see it today
imagine if everyone was moving like at
the same time like imagine if everyone
on the same day was moving oh that's
interesting
just think of what that would it doesn't
sound great I don't I don't even like
going to work when everyone is going to
work it's gonna ruin your thoroughfares
as they're finding out in this time in
1869 a landlord put an agent in charge
of finding a new tenant
or previous everyone moved but he was
very particular about the kind of person
he wanted so took the agent all the way
up until was almost moving day to find a
new tenant and the landlord was getting
worried so he found a tenant on his own
okay the agent also found a tenant so
both tenants then found out about each
other a duel so one of them paid off the
current tenant to leave early and
arrived with his cart of furniture right
after midnight and loaded all of his
furniture in and then the second new
tenant thought he got the jump and he
got there at 5:00 a.m. only to find it
was already occupied and then he sued
the other guy it was how contestants on
reality shows call rooms when they get
let into the house but stuffs here
totally so what happens to this person
at 5:00 a.m. they're just like get out
of luck cuz the other guy was in there
well it's off to jail on moving day the
offices of real estate agents began to
be encircled by crowds full of crying
women who had nowhere to go and whose
belongings have been left on the street
they begged for some kind of shelter and
these scenes why don't you move into
your own
bureaus you got a dress on right okay so
that's good sleep in your drawers sleep
in your drawer you got dresses you got
drawers better you can sleep with all
kinds of options
so these crying women so this leads to
the construction of more buildings
that's their answer that's the I love
that it's great yeah nothing's changed
New York New Yorker Philip Cohen wrote
he and his downtown neighbors were being
offered such high amounts for their
houses that no one could resist so now
there's so many people that need houses
on moving day they're building new
buildings so now they're now they're
buying people's houses out and failing
billing so they in turn to your house
you sell your house but you can't afford
to buy a new house in that area if you
can imagine this
so they went north to live in what used
to be orchards and cornfields so they're
moving
into the outer areas right there old
downtown houses are turned into stores
or torn down made into buildings okay so
moving day hardened boundaries and
segregated the working-class from the
wealthy right right people are all
moving and going in a different
the first may became a scary day for
workers because any kind of setback
during the year could make it impossible
for them to afford housing those work
every year every year those workers had
to you know Eddie Murphy's a little bit
killed my landlord
yeah totally still it's a still
applicable there and applicable now so
those workers had to move to so you have
some something happened whatever
something happens and it costs you money
and you're something had anything so
those those workers had to move to find
cheaper worse housing or bail on owed
back rent and just run out on rent they
owed moving day accelerated the quick
transformation of New York and blew up a
sense of community people could not
remember the house they were born in but
everyone saw moving day as just what was
done the founder of the New York
Historical Society wrote to his daughter
quote Tuesday the first of May hazy bra
it was very unfavorable for the general
moving of our great city high rents
uncomfortable dwellings and necess
neccessity combined to crowd our streets
with carts overloaded with furniture and
hand barrows with sofas chairs sidebars
looking glasses and pictures as to
rented the sidewalks almost impassable
moving a looking glass my god that the
practice of all moving on one day is an
ancient custom and when the city was
small and inhabitants a few in number
but now New York is literally in an
uproar for seven for several days before
and after the first of May this practice
of moving to strangers appears absurd
but it comes with the advantage of
affording a greater choice of homes in
the February quarter but if you have one
you like you're not afforded that but
you but you can find a new great house
no you like this one it's got all the
you're happy I didn't even think of it
if it rains Oh
I mean if it rains yeah I mean just
everybody your stuffs gone nobody's got
stuff I mean it's a I assume they picked
May 1st cuz May 1st that's usually when
it may have changed cuz there's a thing
called climate change but that's usually
when weather is pretty good in New York
that it's the one of two or three spring
weeks that they actually have yeah but
sure can rain absolutely but it's more
likely to rain in the summer or the
winter sure yeah right or what you could
do is you could say first nice day of
May but now New York Times quote it
would be the easiest matter in the world
to break it up if it were desirable but
as moving as a necessity in this moving
age the media is the same even the media
well look in the Trump era it is
infinitely better that all the moving
should take place on one day and then
the hurly-burly is over for the year
that's right for 11 months or worried
about the whole 11 months
everybody grumbles about moving yet
everybody moves so we are compelled to
believe that moving day is a natural and
beneficial institution you're being told
the lead and the legitimate outgrowth of
our political Constitution like dumb
dumb idiots the media and so it went on
by 1880 we are 260 years into moving day
the same stories that appeared in the
papers a hundred years before written
again on moving day carts loaded high
kids helping Cartman being annoying one
author claimed it was because city
dwellers craved variety in 1890 the
legal rules for Cartman were published
in the time is $2.00 for a load on a
one-horse truck within 2 miles 50 cents
for each additional mile 50 cents to
load and unload on the first floor 25
cents for each additional flight of
stairs
of course they just charge what they
wanted anyway sure either way by 1900
about a million New Yorkers were
switching housing in just 24 hours
what a million think it's you a million
kids loved moving day they were usually
taken out of school for weeks to help
with the move and New York schools
declared moving day of school holiday
what other option really in 1901 the
other way you might have new students
tomorrow because they're going in 1901
the New York Times reported that
expensive uptown residences had been
changing their lease month to October to
allow people to store their stuff and
move after they went on vacation for the
summer so rich people are changing their
moving day these buggers have made
first-class yeah but the rest of the
city is still going at it on May the 1st
and things have gotten worse by the way
what's vacation time it's just you go
somewhere the Hamptons it's so like that
deal huh like when Pope right you're
right you're American so it's called the
holiday a lot of Europeans call it that
but it's at this time when you don't
work and you get but you still get paid
but you can get to go and take a
vacation no you go to it seemed like a
rational gentleman and then you come
over here and you spew nonsense well no
mozo on vacation most Europeans get like
a six-week vacate a one-year they'll
take a six-week vacation how can you
afford to keep living will you get paid
for all right my friend we've tried
tried to sort through this while you're
not working the law that you get while
you're not working they're paying you
yeah yeah because because you've done
labor for them you've produced for them
over the years so they owe you yeah
because you are worth since right yes
I'm in the Hawaiian sands getting paid
of course my friend yes yes hey want to
buy a genie lamp
uh so so for the not wealthy moving days
got Moore's quote occupants of the
cheaper apartments and tenements have
been notified by their landlord under
the terms of the law that permits the
landlord to give two hours notice to
vacate on May first once their contract
had expired okay so now people are just
getting kicked out like yeah it any
worse like they think they're gonna stay
and pay the rent and the land which is
kicking them out anyway right it's cool
municipal courts now had extra afternoon
sessions to handle all the landlords who
were taking advantage of moving day oh
my god so now you're adding your adding
going to court in the mix on moving day
it's weird that landlords would take it
advantage of this there's normally good
people they're normally really good on
like New York yes the municipal courts
now had extra day right now so women
complained their husbands had deserted
them and they had no money or anywhere
to go the Bureau of contagious diseases
received a lot of complaints from people
whose landlords were trying to evict
them even though people in the family
were sick and landlords complained
people were trying to avoid paying rent
by claiming someone in the family was
sick like that in 1903
the New York Times said May 1st was no
longer a moving day because the real
estate agents had destroyed the
tradition by switching leases to October
1st an accident doing something good
yeah then in 1904 The Times wrote there
was a low supply of available tenements
because of the shortage property owners
raised rents twenty to thirty percent in
the Lower East Side's where they can
afford it most Stearns several hundred
in the Jewish quarter hit the streets in
protest landlords and they refused to
pay the rent
they were mostly garment workers and
small business men and cannot afford the
existing rent already between a quarter
to a third of their income quote what is
to become of the family whose sole
breadwinner and sixty cents a day whose
rent has been increased from 850 to $13
many lower East Siders felt they quote
lived and worked for the landlord at
least that's gone
yeah well because of subprime mortgages
yeah that's all over now you don't need
to worry about and our government takes
care of us they say no government have a
you should as a as an American you
should have a place to live and then
afford you a decent life they that's
like in the Constitution I'm sorry I'm
thinking of I believe Trump spilled dr.
pepper on the constant that's right
they help protest meetings and went on
rent strikes and even picketed the homes
of landlords they said if they were
kicked out they would spread the word
everywhere that no one would be allowed
to move in okay they printed up cards in
both Yiddish and English warning
neighbors quote to keep away from the
house at whatever blank Street sure but
the house is on strike because the rent
is raised every month and we want to put
a stop to it once and for all everyone
keep away so there you're gonna kick the
[ __ ] out of people if they try to move
it okay I like it I like this this is
again just adding a little more spice to
what's become a really object I think a
rent strike is a really interesting way
to go I mean what better way to spend
May first than getting your head beaten
in with your own lamp imagine what would
happen in this country if all renters
went on a rent strike
oh man having by 1905 The Times wrote
that moving day was much better it was
no longer mayhem quote modern methods
have reduced the operation to a science
a mover in the article said they could
now move someone's possessions in one
load but this was also because the
subway was now in place okay so many
people were able to move to the outer
boroughs and avoid the nightmare of
moving day so they were they were stuck
in this area because they had no choice
they had to go to work and then we get
to work was to walk so now they have a
subway now they can commute to work so
they are less tied down and [ __ ] by a
landlord right this also made wrench
cheaper okay in early 1918 landlords try
to Jack the only one who got turned on
when you said tied down in [ __ ] by a
parent any move are you are you ready to
move okay okay and early nineteen
eighteen landlords tried to jack up rate
saying they had suffered
lean years during the war so World War
one was hard no well that's why it's
known as the landlord since wages and
prices were going up they said they
should be able to make more money there
were more tenant protests then and
strikes in early 1918 judges and
politicians supported the strikers was
shocked and angered the landlords and me
I don't even got in the pocket to one
Bronx owner quote tenants control our
property move in and out of it as they
please pay rent or withhold it as they
please and treat the landlord's well or
ignore them as they please politicians
seeking votes are now organizing
disgruntled tenants to oppose the rights
of landlords Oh amazing
I mean amazing rights of the layoffs of
that gripe is so fantastic yeah you know
they're just coming and going as they
please while paying rent do you want to
be human but also it's like that's
exactly what it is yeah
you rent no because of the times moving
day that year was now October 1st 1918
and the landlord's tried to raise rents
again thousands of renters prepared to
resist many didn't have a choice because
there were no apartments available and
they were being threatened with a hike
of 25 to 30 dollars a month which was up
from 12 to 15 dollars the year before so
they're like [ __ ] doubling the rent
it's time Dave yeah Cartman they're
still a nightmare they charged someone
as much as a week's wages to move the
times wrote quote how much of the
furniture would reach its destination as
furniture and how much would reach it as
firewood in nineteen nineteen ninety six
thousand six hundred and twenty three
families faced eviction judges were now
hearing several hundred cases a day so
many that they had to introduce Night
Court oh my god
often a tenant will be allowed to pay is
old rent for another month and then
vacate because of this October 1st 1919
moving day was described as the most
congested in New York history there were
just 75,000 families in the Bronx and
Manhattan
departments a paper quote this year they
cut themselves among the lucky if they
have any place to go at all
one braccia Bronx judge wrote the large
amount of eviction proceedings was
causing distress which made tenants easy
prey for Bolsheviks and other radicals
oh no oh god forbid these poor [ __ ]
people are getting [ __ ] get together
and imagine oh not socialism they're
discussing again the next year on april
of nineteen twenty new york state
adopted emergency rent laws now if a
tenant challenged a rent increase it was
reviewed for a reasonableness case is
increased during night that during late
nineteen twenty and early nineteen
twenty one and it became overwhelming a
judge in the bronx said it would take
several years to hear all the cases and
that the state was not hiring enough
additional clerks and it did not have
enough courtrooms but nothing was done
in 1925 the courts were clogged with
rent cases when a tenant contested a
rent increase he was assured of his old
rent until the case was heard okay so I
can go offer a year like that but if the
tenant lost he would have to pay the
increase retroactively instead families
would move right before I went to trial
ah that's smart yeah landlords were
encouraged to sue because they were
assured the old rent so they're sure do
rent so they can sue people to get them
out and then they can include legal
costs so it's literally no loss for a
landlord to sue a renter right no
there's no absolutely nothing against
yeah such a total [ __ ] show cases are
piling on judges at some point decided
to come up with their own solution so
the judges all got together and they're
like let's [ __ ] fix this [ __ ] because
the state is not okay they stopped the
landlord's from bringing suits from far
away which they were doing so they would
so a person lives in Greenwich Village
and they would file the suit out in
Queens okay because it's hard for the
tenant to travel
kena has to work right right so the tent
now has to go to court and travel okay
so they made they made them charge
wherever the building was they made them
file the surprise maybe these now on the
side of the tenant and the judges agreed
that a reasonable rent would give the
landlord an eight percent profit of the
market value of his property okay that's
what so now they're like you can't
double it or go crazy so that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah but I mean compared people
probably like well finally some
reasonable solutions and then world war
two came men who worked in the moving
industry were drafted to fight in the
war the ones who remained in the US went
to work in the defense industry making
weapons making cars the moving industry
had no labor finally in New York's
started a rent control program in 1943
and that's when moving day ended in 1943
moving day did not end in 1943 people
are getting [ __ ] relentlessly by
landlords it does not end until there's
no one left to move stuff right that's
when it ends yeah up until then they're
like yeah I just couldn't [ __ ] people
right that is we took a world war three
hundred and twenty years of moving day
of just [ __ ] people and just annual
continuing nightmare nightmare that my
friend is the free market and we love it
you're listening to the libertarian
podcast the librarian lie Berto sorry
libertarian why that just seems like a
dig it is so at the end of World War two
gi's vets flooded the city and the
population of America exploded again
house moving day been going oh you're
not gonna believe it George
gone we stopped the headline in 1945 was
quote housing shortage erases moving day
man you know we just got back from war
yeah we're covering real estate now it's
front page stuff moving day was done the
new housing shortage forced the food
these inhabitants to stay where they
lived and with rent control they could
moving day eventually faded from the
memories of all New Yorkers man it's
like traffic laws but buildings it's
just like I mean just you just like like
no one has ever given a [ __ ] about
people no it is you have to be like a
hockey goalie like with the amount of
blocking of like [ __ ] that they're
going to try to do of you just coming at
you all the time yeah it's just
Oh anytime you cut off one head there's
another one pops up you cannot there's
just you can't they're just greed is the
strongest evil in the world today so I'm
up we're we're gonna start cutting it
off after and just putting up the extra
stuff we talked about our path right
dial up after dark or table after dark
we're back here today we're in this
totally [ __ ] rent place and something
has to break yeah right yes
like people are paying I was just
talking to someone oh so there's a guy
we know this guy someone just told my
story I know and it'll come up like this
I do people like this in New York broke
they have a brother living the other
they break up and neither one can move
out so they're living together and they
can't move and you're in a one-bedroom
apartment with someone you used to be in
a relationship with yeah Danny Novak's
have you stuck there man I in my family
have had a couple situations where the
yeah people are no longer compatible and
they have no choice because there's
dances but to stay and try to figure out
the weirdest so now your scenario in the
situation where you're stressed and
living in a nightmare and just going to
your job and your whole [ __ ] life is
how that's pretty cool when I lived in
New York I'm moving away Dave they're
making it so that you never want to go
home which is kind of a good
when I lived in New York I lived in this
building for two years on the Upper West
Side and it was cheap it was like a
little studio and then I was walking out
of the building one day and this guy who
lived there he's coming down the
elevator him he goes you know this is
rent control right and I go yeah he goes
find out what your rent is I know what
do you mean he goes there's a place
downtown where they list how much your
rent should be and then how much you pay
and then and then how much you're paying
and I know what he was charging me $150
more a month and so I went down to this
[ __ ] place and I look up the listing
and he's literally charging me 200 more
dollars a month then he's legally
allowed to and just fudging the books
and then showing that to the city and me
I'm like yeah no I only took this amount
and so I go to him and I go dude I've
been living here for [ __ ] two years
you have a rent-controlled building
which now explains why you [ __ ] treat
us all like [ __ ] and don't take care of
it because he wants all that he was
trying to get all the everyone to leave
so he's treating everyone like [ __ ] and
charging me more and I and I call him on
it and he just [ __ ] laughs and goes
oh yeah I'll give it back to you dude he
just [ __ ] laughed it was like yeah
yeah okay I put in the work I'm gonna
reward you don't tell the others
so this this episode just makes me think
of climate change totally right totally
the parallels are extraordinary because
it isn't I mean as we know it's like
that's what we talked about like the way
to move the like he pending calamity to
move that feeling up when it's you're
not feeling it it's like boy in high
school a friend of Mines dad was a
[ __ ] lifetime smoker right he goes to
the doctor one day doctor says he has
cancer he never smoked another cigarette
now if he had 10 years prior taking the
mentality that the doctor put in his
head when he told them you
have cancer he would have probably lived
20 years longer but he couldn't get his
head around the idea that he couldn't
smoke couldn't imagine his life without
cigarettes so he kept smoking until it
was too late then he stopped and died
because then he had cancer it was too
late yes which is what's happening now
yes and it's like this is such a great
example of like you just because it's
the way it is
you just [ __ ] stay in it it's it's
like yes it snort I mean it's normalcy
normalcy is just what we cling to I mean
you know it's every time literally every
time I go buy a new a thing of detergent
I'm like this has got to stop yes he's
like crazy yeah but you like the amount
because I'm soup I've become super
conscious of how much [ __ ] I'm using the
plastics the plastic that I am now so
yeah your track so you try to avoid
plastic and then you realize how much
like if you focus on plastic oh yeah and
you said you realize how much [ __ ]
plastic you use yeah and how hard it is
to not use it I look forward to a world
where the term non plastic is like
nonsmoker
vegan like whatever it's just one of the
non groups it's when you call a
restaurant and you want takeout and you
say I'm not plastic they go yeah we
cater to not button yes do you remember
the episode of Mad Men when they have a
picnic and then they drive away and they
leave the picnic the trash just sitting
on the that's what we're doing with the
world yeah and then there's just little
[ __ ] like I tweeted something and
someone was like have you ever tried
shampoo bars don't shampoo bars on it's
just a [ __ ] bar that's like a soap
bar fight you just rub it on your head
right so now you're not buying shampoo
in a plastic bottle right so I
immediately there is a store near me
that sells and I went I'm bottom they're
[ __ ] great it's better than shampoo
there there are ways to do it
like I guess we're rambling on so people
can stop but have you seen our trigger I
think it was a trigger warning or
triggered then killer Mike show on
Netflix we've seen it oh I haven't
watched it yet there is it's interesting
it's different than what you would
probably expect but there's the I think
it's the first one
he's like he's only going to for like
three days or something only going to
live on products that are made by and
profit benefits the black community oh
[ __ ] and so he's now like like he can't
smoke weed like again at all not like
it's like a heightened thing but it
definitely displays the point of like he
starts having you know when you source
your stuff that's why I love going to
the farmers market so it's like when you
source your stuff and you actually start
to know people who are like yeah more
that you could take money away that's
really what the goal is just every step
you can take towards that is better the
more that you can take the money away
from the big places the more that you
could not get I'm not people at
different situations people can afford
different things but more the less that
you're giving your money to Walmart and
the more that you're giving your money
to a mom-and-pop or whatever it is the
more that you can just like focus money
on places that actually have
characteristics that you identify with
as people or places or companies that
are going to stop just not giving a [ __ ]
yeah the more that you can do that the
more these big companies that don't want
you to give a [ __ ] will start to give a
[ __ ] when you're diverting your
attention else but at the end of the day
this episode just makes me think there
has to be a general strike there has to
be a rent strike there has to be a
everybody just shuts it down because it
sleep we are so off the path of how the
[ __ ] this can work and you think about
like the honestly the fear that must go
through them when they feel what
happened with the workers yeah the other
day like just the like and the teachers
and teachers right it's happening more
and more and they got a genius like orgy
teachers Oklahoma teachers LA teachers
now Denver teachers are going on strike
so the more that they see that the more
scared than yeah because they're and
they have to be scared we have to scare
them dude it's like when the
Velociraptor opens a door in Jurassic
Park it's time for clever girl yeah and
these people in New York let it go on
for 300 years and they should have shut
it now and at some point way but [ __ ]
before that I just said know the
difference what you're gonna do you can
build new buildings and you can change
rent
there's not enough lumber for a new
planet we will live on bark bark the
bark houses well it's probably good time
to tell people to go follow planet
change town yeah planet change 10 that's
our environmental group at the weave
store and Aaron from all things comedy
has promised us that we're gonna start
to get little clips when we come down
here to film that we can post on
Instagram little right Aaron what are we
doing yeah we talked about it little
clips well teaser clips from the show
okay bye